hello I am Lee gives a post-doctoral
research fellow and associate in the
department of translational genomics at
Keck School of Medicine at the
University of Southern California I
would like to thank lab roots for
inviting me to speak at this precision
medicine 2019 webinar definitely a
privilege to be able to talk to you
about some of the things that we have
gone on under the umbrella of the
technologies that we believe are novel
approaches for assessing molecular
heterogeneity in cancer this is
something that heterogeneity is
something that definitely is trivial and
challenging when you think about
targeted therapies as well as why
patients some patients respond and some
patients do not respond to some therapy
some patients have a response and and
then all of a sudden the cancer comes
back and then there's some patients that
just blow right through the treatment
and you have to go with switching from
one therapy to the next to the next to
the next using bulk sequencing we
believe that some of the things that are
coming out in the technology field in
the genomics arena will really help us
resolve some of those challenges and
propel us into the future of how to
really have precision medicine and
personalized therapy for each patient so
thinking about tumor heterogeneity on
this various cons for example this
heterogeneity from one patient to the
next this heterogeneity within one tumor
you can have multiple different clones
in one tumor that cellular heterogeneity
and when you think about that you're
thinking about the tumor micro
environment of the milieu of different
populations of cells that vary from one
tumor that's located in the body maybe
in the breast or prostate versus the
lungs as well as genomic heterogeneity
as also you have epigenetic
heterogeneity so so definitely there's
different levels to this and and you
know there's different technologies that
will allow you to assess this and
different methods so when we think about
in relation to intra tumor heterogeneity
this figure right here where you see a
patient that has primary breast cancer
and when you take out that breast cancer
that tumor itself you can see up top
that it has different dominance of
different zones that are within that one
tumor so if you have one or two or three
four clones right you will want to be
able to say which clone goes to which
organ is it that you have one major
clone that actually causes the evolution
of the tumor and then there are there's
branched evolution that comes from this
tumor where you have one clone that is
able to metastasize and reside in the
liver or there's another clone that's
able to move to the brain and reside
there or it does it all look the same if
we would take the liver I'll take the
brain out you know would it just look
just like the breast tumor itself so
that's what we mean when we are thinking
of intra two more heterogeneity within
one cancer on the genetic level there's
these structural variations called copy
number variations
these are alteration of the DNA of a
genome that results in the cell having
an abnormal or for certain genes and
normal variation in the number of copies
of one or more sections of the DNA copy
number variations correspond to
relatively large regions of the genome
that have been deleted fewer than the
normal number meaning that if a person
supposed to be diploid meaning that they
should have two
biess one inherited from their mother
one heritage from father there could be
a possibility where one is deleted or
both is deleted results in the
homozygous deletion in that region of
the genome or it could be duplicated for
more than the normal number meaning that
instead of two copies there's a
individual that has a amplification or
gains of different number of regions of
their genome meaning instead of two this
person will have four copies six copies
a tenth and for cancer it could be 20 30
40 copies of that specific part of the
genome where genes that could be uncle
genes or tumor suppressors reside which
would be very important to know and when
we're thinking about cancer so tumor
heterogeneity exists and standard
profiling methods of bulk specimens can
mask important sub clonal populations
that have acquired specific events that
drive aggressive behaviors and
metastatic potential although deep
sequencing might identify low frequency
and point mutations the cyclin copy
number employee changes in mixed cell
population is more difficult because the
signal gets diluted particularly for
copy number changes so to give you a
realistic idea of what what this may
look like something that could be
analogous to everyday life picture that
you have a smoothie and when you put a
straw in that smoothie you can say that
hey this must be a strawberry or
strawberry banana smoothie but you
really don't know all the ingredients
that was put into that smoothie to make
it be that smooth and anybody that has
made a smoothie before knows that
although there's a dominant taste that
comes out of this movie there were
different ingredients that was put into
this movie so bulk sequencing is almost
taking a straw to a tumor and saying
that you know everything about that
tumor based on
using this bulk approach we just grind
everything up of their tumor and then
you say okay when I sequence this tumor
or whatever is the largest signal of
their tumor in the case of the smoothie
if it's a strawberry smoothie you want
to taste strawberry right but when we
think about on the single-cell level
you miss that information you really
don't know what really is the molecular
parts of their tumor that makes up that
tumor that gives it that intra tumor
heterogeneity so single-cell sequencing
is will really allow you to see that to
say that hey not only is this a
strawberry smoothie this strawberry
smoothie has but now this strawberry
smoothie has a little orange or mint or
whatever else that was put inside of
this smoothie so outside of using fish
on fluorescence in situ hybridisation
single-cell analysis holds the most
promise for identifying clonal
populations that have drivers that are
altered by copy number changes current
single cell DNA methods rely on highly
laborious brute force techniques thus
there exists the need for novel
approaches to generating genome-wide
sequencing libraries from single cells
so we believe in our department
implementing 10x genomics single-cell
seemly technologies to access clonal
evolution luncheon to lien cancers were
really allow us to understand our only
intra tumor heterogeneity also
heterogeneity within the population of
patients for a specific subtype of
cancer so now we're going to look at a
video that actually shows a little bit
how this technology is working on a Pico
scale level within the microfluidic
chips that ten-inch uses to do the to
create the single cell libraries
you
since L copy numbers technology really
is is automated by the 10x genomics
workflow so single cells as you see in
step one are encapsulated in droplets
using oil emulsion then cell lysis
occurs and bees to release the actual
genome and cell bees are mixed with gel
beats each containing a unique barcode
and unique 10x barcode then you will
have this cell be gel gel bt moshe or
the CBGB as ten-inch refers to it it's
performed two is performed to create
beads that contain a single genome and a
single barcode library primers since the
libraries are created by where each
sales library fragments and a march with
a unique barcode then you take those
libraries and you will sequence them on
an Illumina platform short read
sequencing system and then the single
cell data that comes off will provide
true ploidy
using 10x algorithm to actually call
copy number variation so in our
experimental design we really want to
focus on a pilot study to really see how
could this technology be used in the
realm of cancers that are heterogeneous
so we wanted to think about using these
three cell lines which were actually
derived by Fred Miller from one
particular Mouse train on the Bobbsey
Mouse train that actually creates tumors
on his own already as it ages and Fred
Miller actually took this tumor out and
actually put them under different
pressures to derive a the cell line 67
in R which is non metastatic 168 foreign
which is weakly metastatic and 41 which
is highly metastatic and our next part
of this polish study
we wanted to take the Bobbsey mouse
which this trainer which is the sister
cell line that she's arrived from and
inject them into the memory fat pad of
the mouse and actually look at the tumor
as it's within his own tumor
microenvironment with all the pressures
that a human would normally have because
this mouse is actually immunocompetent
so for our first part of this workflow
we culture T cell line six seven in our
1c state form 41's
and this is pretty much all of the
machine the machines and technology that
you will need to perform this workflow
you would need a countess for automated
cell counting counting it's very
important when you think about singing
cells and arguer cells actually clump
together are your cells dead are your
cells necrotic those things that you
will be able to observe in the automated
sales counter by counters and then the
10x is where you actually generate the
gems the gel beads and emulsion and you
will did all that with library
preparation for sequencing on the
Illumina Novus e6000 system you will
need about 1.5 million reads per cell to
get a minimum of two mega base
resolution for copy number Colleen Moore
sequencing of course you can see more
for is thinking about copy numbers that
are for those small genes at the gene
level but definitely 10x recommends
about 1.5 million reads per sale they'll
get you about at least 0.1 0.2 X
coverage per cell which is really good
for calling structure variation when you
think about each cell represents a whole
genome so if you have 455 cells they
essentially you have a forager than 55
whole genomes that's like sequencing 455
patience but they're all being sampled
from the same tumor then you have to do
data processing of course when you have
this level of we when you have this high
amount of patient samples on definitely
if you want something done in a large
amount of time you want to increase the
amount of computing computational power
that you have you want to increase the
amount of memory so it really depends on
how fast you want this to work we
recommend I should see here at minimum
you should have 128 gigabyte RAM you
want two terabytes of storage for about
every 1.5 billion reads that you are
actually analyzing 24 cores solid-state
disk or really help we speed this up
with the rewrite capacity so that's
really important but what's really cool
that 10x has is they have the pipeline
already available which is the cell
range or DNA pipeline which actually
does all the pipeline compilation for
you so you don't actually have to put
together a pipeline like you would
normally do for some of you know
something for those of you they do
Illumina sequence and understand that
you have to pretty much put those
pipelines together to do be still too
fast queue and then fast queue to bands
and then Bam's and you're trying to
figure out which program that's gonna
analyze the best 10 X is already done
that work on the front end for you you
would just have to do the back end
analysis but what's cool about really
cool about the cell range DNA pipeline
is that it comes out with all of these
different files that you can use to
really help you jump-start your detailed
analysis that you want to do for this
copy number variation analysis so two
things that we're going to look at in
particular is the loop visualization
file
that actually goes into tonight's loot
single cell DNA browser and then was
also highlighted in red we're gonna look
at at the bottom which is the run
summary HTML which provides some GC for
quality on what we actually put in and
what we actually were able to get out of
our libraries out of our sequencing to
make sure that you know if our target
was 500 cells did we get 250 cells did
we get 300 cells back did we get a
thousand cells that's very important
when you think about even going forward
sequencing and having that type of
information by maybe doing a small
monastic run first to really get that QC
analysis so you can know which flow
cells you would like to use from
Illumina also what comes off this is a
position sort of bound position sort of
an index which you can throw not a GB so
you can actually look through and
actually see the reeds and see what's
actually being called and where it's
located seeing because with that with
imputation and seen because without
Holley number regions you will have her
sales summary metrics analysis summary
metrics and of course hdf5 file with
with seeing me data so Luke seems so DNA
a browser which we're gonna focus a lot
on really helps you visualize the
copying on the information produced from
the single-cell DNA data is a pretty
much essentially like a igv for single
cell whole genome copy number analysis
and we'll get to that but first we want
to do is look at the web some HTML so
our first sample was 67 in our target
was 500 cells from our summary which you
see the first arrow pointing to the
fortune 56 estimate number of cells
that's what we actually got back we
actually recovered from our single cell
libraries and
also get some metrics about you know the
medium effective reads per megabase
meeting a mapped French and per cell
reads from cells the median average
ploidy and some really cool other
metrics that you can go really deep into
to really see the quality of the data so
you can make sure what's being called is
actually real and not an artifact and
another thing that's really cool is it
gives you a media employee of what is
that actual genome is it a diploid it's
mostly a diploid genome is it triploid
tetraploid and here 467 in our what is
calling is a triploid Mouse cancer
genome at about 3.25 media employee we
also get some metrics on reads per cell
we have a histogram here with number of
reads at the bottom and number of cells
is actually sequencing at that depth how
many cells are actually there and then
you have a cell pody histogram they
actually a breakdown of the average
ploidy and how many number of cells have
that ploidy and you see here while it's
calling it a triple announced cancer
genome because we see that a large
number of cells average Claudie across
the entire genome was around 3 but you
also have some cells that around 6:00
Sunday around 2:00 so you really see
from right here you can see some
heterogeneity going on even from the QC
reports and also you get for those of
you that are familiar with Illumina
sequencing those fraction of the queue
31 bases cute 32 bases total reads just
almost like for those that have done any
informatics with Illumina data this is
pretty much knowledge as to the multi QC
reports that people pull out and use to
make sure that the sequencing was done
right and we actually reached a target
number of cells our target number of
reads and so this is very important to
take a first look at this so just make
sure that what you're
seeing is actually something of a
validation already from the chief see
report saying that this is worth looking
at so this is a actual loop
visualization file of the cell line 67
in R and I'm gonna walk through a little
bit of what you're actually looking at
um so this is a heatmap employee across
the entire genome for each individual
cell without looking at the things that
I'm pointing out with the arrows we just
want to look at where we see two per
sorry from the left to the right with
the number one atop all the way to
number 19 X&Y
what you have here is from left to right
you have the whole genome being
represented from left to right from
looking at chromosome 1 chromosome 2 3 4
all the way to chromosome 19 which might
have 19 autosomes and a pair of sex
chromosomes and then looking from the
top to the bottom when you look at the
actual heat map each row represents the
individual cell so when you look down
going from top to the bottom
this actually represents 456 single
cells so here you have single cell copy
number profiles for 456 whole genomes
looking at the left where it says heat
map and you see where it says copy
number a and there's zeros 16 plus with
0 representing this darkest blue all the
way to 16 where whereas representing
black you have the cup the color blue
represent 0 meaning that is a homozygous
deletion or in this area there is a loss
of two copies one is light blue
represents
a genomic region that has one copy of
their gene meaning that one may have
been deleted and then you have this gray
area where represents two which means
that this is an area where is diploid or
normal and then with three which we
talked about earlier this is a triploid
cancer genome so as you see is mostly
this color which is like a oranges
peaches type color peach type of color
that means that you have gained a copy
and then as you go higher from four to
sixteen it means that you have gained
more copies of the chromosome region and
these would be gangs for about three to
two to eight copies and then eight or
greater we will call highly amplified
regions so looking across on their just
thinking about this first arrow we
really do see some heterogeneity when
you look at the three regions then I'm
pointing it and you can really identify
this by just looking at the X chromosome
where you have for this first arrow up
top you have this peach colored area
whether it means that you have a gain of
chromosome export these cluster of cells
and then when we point in here you look
looks like you have this loss for the
second arrow location of the P arm of
chromosome X and the rest is diploid and
then it looks like for where I'm
pointing with this third arrow arrow
that you have a large amount of sales
that have a loss of one copy of X and
the places where I'm certainly are these
areas where everything looks the same
based off this second arrow if you go to
the second arrow location you see where
is it that this is the cluster of cells
that have the loss of the one one copy
loss of EP arm of chromosome X but when
we move to the left and go to chromosome
three where we have this red circle and
it's highlighted with this cream
color of green globe you see that in the
middle chromosome three and we returned
my chromosome three is actually
representing from left to right the P
arm to the Q arm so right in the middle
probably write a little bit over the Q
arm you have this amplification of these
cells that none of this new
amplification in the middle of
chromosome three and then as we move to
the right we see different games in this
square box this rectangular box with
this red box and green glow you see that
you have these new gains on chromosome
12 in some of these cells but not in
others so this is just one
representation of heterogeneity anybody
that is chrome cell lines know that it's
three different groups three different
labs or three different people in the
lab grow three different batches of cell
lines and we did the single cell copy
numbers experiment there would be some
heterogeneity just because of the
pressure of growing in a 2d culture on
top of each other the different things
that arise it was really cool to to see
this in a cell line that that it
actually has heterogeneity and you know
even be cooler if you did another 67
nr from a lab across the world cuz I'm
pretty sure there would be some
different gains and losses of different
clusters of cells and those as well and
was really cool about this and something
I didn't point out in the beginning of
talking about this is this bottom area
where you see this trace going from
chromosome 1 to chromosome Y it almost
looks like a EKG at the bottom and this
green line represents diploid I mean you
have you know the average seen B calls
alone that chromosome so this is what
we're calling a pseudo bull trace this
way it would look like if we did bulk
sequencing we did both sequencing we
would do a CGH array we would give
something back they look very similar to
these traces
but what we don't have what this doesn't
represent is when you do both seat was
saying what would it look like for a
small cluster of sales that maybe
doesn't it doesn't look like this so you
really drown out the signal will you
average out these sales of some very
important clusters here and even when
you think about chromosome X it's saying
from this pseudo ball Trace that it's
mostly diploid as you see that black
line covers that green line because on
average when you have an area that's to
an area of set of group of cells that
have an average of 3 and a group of
cells they have an average of 1 then
that would probably average out to be
around 2 but we know from looking at
these single cell traces when we look at
where these arrows are pointing that's
definitely heterogeneity that is being
masked by the taking the average of
these cells for that given genomic
region so it's very interesting so I
probably won't go too further with
explaining the detail of the heat map
I'm just gonna probably scroll through I
think and show some pictures of what
these other cells lines look like but I
wanted to give a really good description
of what we're looking at here so
everyone audience to have a chance to
really follow follow along as I go
through I'm looking at these other poly
cases so for cell lines once you say
foreign best-made number of cells that
we got back was 313 and the media
employee was around 2.5 so we could say
is a little bit it probably was mostly
diploid you could suggest for from this
but there's probably some regions of
different parts of the genome that may
be amplified and we could kind of see
that when we look at this cell pointing
history
and you can look across and see that
there's different cells with different
average ploidies so looking at the
weekly metastatic barium wants to 684
and you can see here what is being
called mostly diploid as you see there
are a lot of different chromosomes here
for example chromosome four chromosome
five eight nine ten where it's mostly
diploid across the genome but we do see
some heterogeneity here when we look at
it once you say for in it and I'm trying
to point that out with these arrows here
so you see that you know on the X
chromosome just looking there you can
see that there's this group of these
cluster of cells here where you have a
loss of this peak on it to almost as QR
of chromosome X and then you have his
next cluster of cells when I'm pointing
the second arrow where you see that they
have lost another region of the n of X
which represents the entire S chromosome
has lost a copy for these cells but also
you see where I'm circling with this red
green glow circle then you have these
other cells or chromosome 14 that have
lost another portion going closer to the
P arm of chromosome 14 whereas these
cells as you look at the P arm a
chromosome 14 most of the cells have a
gain of chromosome 14 but here you have
and some cells that are deployed for the
Pima chromosome 14 and now they have
lost another region of chromosome 14 so
that's very interesting and another way
to think about looking at clone ality
and then we have the cell line 14 one
where we've recovered 497 cells and the
41 cell on itself is known to be riddled
with amplifications crosstie and the
entire genome and here we're calling a
tetraploid
mouths cancer genome which is a non
surprise this cell line has been studied
for a long period of time and it's very
aggressive and it's often riddled with
regions that are that are either gangs
or high home vacations so we're really
excited to see this represented by this
single cell technology from 10x and also
was really cool here's and we look at
the cell ploidy histogram we can see
that the average number the average
number of cells 120 cells they have
around an average Claudia 4 and that's
really cool to see that there are cells
that do not have all those average
average ploys of four so I'm always
excited when I when I look at these runs
certain html's
because I just can't wait to open up
this in the loop browser to actually see
what do these cells actually look look
like here I'm getting averages but with
the visualization about I'm actually to
go in-depth on a single cell level and
look across the whole genome and really
put this in reality and real person in a
in a real tangible aspect which is
something that you know for someone that
has done a lot of both sequence and
that's something that you can never do
with both sequencing so so this is this
is really cool so when we look at the 41
highly metastatic bearing it we
definitely see you know regions that
look you know like each other some
regions that look different from each
other
I mean his is a lot going on here what's
really cool about this is that
chromosome 9 and chromosome 15 because
that's what 41 that's that's a hallmark
a feature of 41 cell line of the 14 one
cell line you have these amplifications
these pair of implications of chromosome
I and this trio of amplifications on
chromosome 15 so it's really cool too
for anyone that studied before t1 cell I
know for anyone that has done both
sequencing when you're able to see
something that should be there as is you
know that you've seen before and with
the new technology that just gives you
confidence that the technology that
you're using is doing what it's supposed
to do and even more and adding more than
what you would normally do so we're
seeing things on a single-cell level but
it's not taking away from anything that
we knew before it's only add so that's
really cool because that's what this
technology was meant for so when we look
across we really see that the
single-cell profiles look very different
and just from these pseudo bulb traces
underneath each heat map you can see
that you could have witnessed that from
doing volt sequencing you could have saw
that these three were very different
from each other but one thing that you
could not see is how each cell is
different from each other within one
cell line or in one tumor so it really
shows the power of using this technology
when you're thinking about intra tumor
heterogeneity going further on to
thinking about you know looking at
branched evolution so for our next part
of this polish study we're focusing on
the 41 cell line and we're injecting
that into the memory fat pad of the
mouse as I said before and we take that
tumor out we use military biotechs
genomics
octal dissociate ER for tissue
dissociation and then we followed the
same protocols as before which is
automated cell counting gem generation
single-cell sequencing on that on the
Illumina six 6000 data processing using
the cell Ranger DNA pipeline and
and Luke visualization some things that
I do want to point out about the tissue
about the teachers association protocol
that we use for dissociating to Bible
single cells for the single cell
sequencing and as we look at slide to
mean the the next slide scuse me
we see that the injection site tumor was
about 31% viability he was doing
single-cell RNA sequencing you'll
probably want to do it this a removal to
actually clean this up because
single-cell RNA sequencing is less
forgiving when it comes to samples that
are that they have poor viability in the
case of our injection site tumor 14:1
when you actually inject it to a Bobbsey
Mouse becomes a highly all ulcerative so
you would definitely have to sacrifice
these mice a little bit earlier than
normal so if you can imagine the tumors
actually black on the outside because
this is all serrated so when we actually
take the tumor out we try to cut as much
as possible that the black necrotic area
out of that tumor before we do the
dissociation but still poor viability
remains because of course you know
there's highly aggressive you have
apoptosis go apoptosis is going on you
have the Krause was going on and so the
really forgiving part about single cell
copy number or working with sync or
doing a single cell DNA in general is
that as long as the nuclide or intact
and they're able to move into the step
where you actually through the GLB
emulsion step to create the gems the
single cell libraries as long as the new
clot is intact then you're fine the
problem comes is when new class start
the lies but in this case you like I
said it's a little bit more less
challenging dealing with
poor viral samples and irishman in our
experience with single-cell DNA also in
our experience if you try this with
singles RNA with the poor viable sample
you know you're gonna be highly upset at
the results that you'll see you will
want to do it this era move we also took
out the lung liver and spleen and we
used email teeny kids for the mounts
tumor long liver explains we didn't
change anything the only thing that we
do after we do association is to do a
quick red blood cell lysis we do that
because you don't want to spend you know
your your your dollars on sequencing red
blood cells if you're looking at a solid
tumor I want to look at intro tumor
heterogeneity so we do the blood red
blood cell lysis to to get rid of red
blood cells so we can focus our our
money and computational time and
analysis on actually looking at as many
tumor cells as possible so looking at
the histopathology of these different
areas that we took out we also took out
the brain even though we did not do
brain dissociation but just to take a
look we did not see any detectable tumor
in the cerebellum or the hippocampus we
did see multiple tumor foci in the liver
as well as we saw tumor cell
infiltration and the spleen so we're
pointing at this red pulp and white pulp
which are normal features of a spleen on
the rest of the lighter purple is
colored cells are all tumor cells
scattered throughout the spleen in the
lung which is the left third box from
the bottom we see no detectable tumor
and on the right of that where it says
primary tumor all of that red that you
that all of the purple that you see
there is representing tumor cells so it
was a huge tumor on a grew in about 14
21 days and when it's sacrificed a
little bit earlier than expected because
the
the the aggression of the tumor really
calls for the mouse to be euthanized a
little bit earlier than we expected so
looking at the injection site tumor our
target was 500 we recovered 246 cells
not bad we actually have about 2.5
million reads per cell so we went about
1 million cells a 1 million reads over
the expected Reese per cell which is
about 1.5 million reads 10 x says you
should use to see at least a 2 mega base
resolution and we see that we're calling
the tetraploid Mouse cancer genome not
surprising 41 is a tetraploid Mouse
cancer genome as we showed earlier so
it's not surprising that the tumor
itself would be a tetraploid Mouse
cancer genome and here's the interesting
part
so looking at the cell ploidy histogram
you see definitely we have to represent
of populations of cells here when we
look around average Florio 2 we see we
have about 70 odd cells then our average
cláudio - and I'll talk about why that
is I'm in this next slide and for the
average 4004 as we expect from the
average plenty of this tumor being a
tetraploid Mouse cancer genome every
4004 you would expect that you have a
population of cells that have average
plotted for you makes sense
so let's investigate further to see what
the diploid cells are and while they're
there so looking at the heat map of this
we definitely see some things that look
like before this entire kind of peach
oranges area across for the cells at the
top and then we see the cells at the
bottom which are mostly gray while we
have diploid cells there well when you
take out a tumor whether
from a patient or whether this from a
mouse the milieu of cells there are
going to represent a lot of normal
normal cells to begin with that is a
feature of solid tumors that you would
have some normal cell this was that
you're gonna have some tumor cells so
it's really cool to see these things
actually separate from each other in
this single-cell analysis which this is
something that you know for a lot of us
to do bulk sequencing you know if you
have too much normal it will dilute the
tumor signal hey you really can't see
maybe a mutation of interest that you
want to see because you have so much
normal there maybe you can see a
structural variation in a certain
genomic region that you have so much
normal there that it dilutes out the
signal but in the single cell in the
single cell arena is really interesting
how that's not really a significant
problem the only significant problem
that you probably would have this is a
financial one if you spent so much money
you know sequencing 10% of tumor cells
that's in the population so you spent
the money sequence a thousand tumor
cells but 900 of them were were normal
cells that will probably be very
frustrating but for those of us that
have their work with tumor subtypes with
a small amount of tumor content that we
normally get where there's five percent
tumor 10% 20% tumor
you know laser capture microdissection
is really not a factor here where you
have to really go in and say okay I want
to make sure our sequence a lot of tumor
and also I want to sequence three
different locations of the tumor and now
I have to go in and and laser capture
microdissection of tumor cells for a
large number of sides and pull those all
together to actually get to a
concentration that can actually be
sequence here you don't have to worry
about that at all you don't
to do microdissection you do not have to
worry about you know taking in too much
normal or taking in not enough tumor you
don't have to worry about that here
literally we're taking the tumor and
we're doing a gentle dissociation using
the 10 mil tinnies biotech octal
dissociate err once we get single cells
we're jazz putting them through the
library prep sequencing them and see
where everything falls in line through
hierarchical clustering really awesome
here and so not to belabor the point
looking at tumor injection site now
we're able to really see true clonality
in this pilot study you're able to see a
different number of different clones I
mean you could really just peel back
this data like an onion and keep seeing
layers and layers and layers and layers
of different things that will make you
have a aha moment but here we wanted to
point out two significant things one is
that you look at chromosome 9 and
chromosome 15 you're not you you have
this hallmark that is still there which
is this pair of amplification on
chromosome 9 chromosome and this trio of
amplification chromosome 15 that is
throughout every tumor cell that you see
there but we also see three clones that
breakout that was definitely not there
before are the least that we can see in
our sampling of the 500 cells from the
14 one cell line that we injected into
this tumor site so it looks like if you
look at the first starting with the
rectangular box you see them most of the
cells look like that they look like they
have those pair of amplification of
chromosome 9 those tree implication
chromosome 15 some of them may have
gains in certain areas but nothing
really dramatic and when we say dramatic
we've talked to these highly amplified
regions but looking at the first arrow
atop pointing at the appearing of the P
region on chromosome 2 we see that their
cells that have those same hallmarks but
now they have evolved to have this
amplification on the p arm of chromosome
2 and then looking at the at the bottom
where the circle is with the red of the
red circle with a green glow we see that
there's this region with this segmental
amplification on chromosome 3 that
wasn't there before and then she do not
see throughout the cells but they don't
have that highly amplified region on
chromosome 2 so we're really looking at
it looks like this you know three
different calls this is really clone
ality now there would be more studies
that you have to doing more analysis
that you would have to do that actually
say which one evolve first but you can
definitely see that there's some type of
evolution going on within this one tumor
and then you of course you have the
other clone which would be you know
mostly the diploid cells at the bottom
so just zooming into to some of these
these areas as we would with anything
that that we sequence in the tumor world
we want to look at Uncle genes into
suppressors and when we talk about
amplifications
we're mostly thinking about uncle genes
and when we're thinking about tumor
suppressor they're mostly thinking about
regions that are deleted since we don't
really have that means deletions or
deleted regions of the genome here we
really focus on on amplifications in the
context of looking at the 41 to an
injection site so as we zoom in in this
area on chromosome 15 we definitely see
these this amplification on the p armor
chromosome 15 you have this next
amplification if you go from left to
right in the middle of chromosome 15 and
then you have this segmental
amplification on chromosome 15 as well
then was also very very interested if
you look past I said mended
amplification on chromosome 15 if you
move to the right you
see this lying which is this application
that starts from the top all the way to
the bottom and in the diploid so this is
probably something that that is germline
probably something that is in that
dismounts already had was this
amplification that's something that we
all have you know small percentage of
all of our genomes have copy number
changes and for a mouse in this case it
looks like from what we see here is that
this is a germline amplification because
we see it in the diploid and you see it
all the way up until we look into the
tumor and just peeling back then layer a
little bit more when we look at the
error area where the error is we see
that that location underneath there
location
underneath the umbrella of an
amplification we see the gene Mik for
those of you that are unfamiliar with
Uncle Jeannie Mick make regulates a
complex biological program by
transcriptionally activating and
repressing its numerous target genes
gene application emit is the most
commonly observed marker of mikta
regulation in cancer Mika's oncogene is
mostly acknowledged in human breast
cancers with when you have patients that
have this amplification of chromosome 8
so is is very important and interesting
how we saw this you know something that
we see normal human breast cancer
translates to Mouse breast cancers and
we're able to see it you know sequencing
this at a single-cell level you can even
see there's different cells here that
they have different levels of
amplification of Mik so that's really
cool look at this other location and
looking underneath these amplification
on chromosome 15 what's interesting is
that we also see amplification of skin
too and you can see different levels of
amplification of skip 2 and then you can
also notice that you do not see it in
the diploid area let's get it to is
important because they promote your big
word nation
your big litter nation and destruction
of cdh1 in a ck1 dependent manner
thereby regulating cell migration and
that's interesting because this is a
highly metastatic cell lining and you
have skipped to that's being amplified
and Holly I'm finding a lot of these
cells and looking further at chromosome
2 and those sales up top if you look at
those that thick layer of a red of high
of this deep red across chromosome 2
that's where we were looking at earlier
if I could point back to this slide
where the arrow is up top to those cells
that have this P arm application
chromosome
everything bags are in the memory
epithelium and has been reported to
promote breast cancer progression so
this was a definitely interesting pilot
study one you know it's very interesting
because we're really just trying to get
the technology to work in-house
doubtlessly really the purpose of the
pilot study but it but they're trying to
be something very interesting to look at
how we deal with our studies that we're
looking at patients and thinking about
human breast cancers and thinking about
responses to treatment
you know those patients that did
responding and those patients that did
not respond what are we gonna do with
the data that comes out how are we going
to analyze this how are we gonna make
sense of this and tell a story and I
think for those of you that are watching
today have seen many things that you
could do that we've shown and you
probably have thought of another million
different ways to analyze this data I
mean you could really just go deeper and
deeper and deeper and and take out Excel
sheets and employee calls that look at
individual cluster of cluster of cells
and even think about you know taking
clusters and comparing them to the
diploid because now you have germline
whole genome sequencing information and
then you can start thinking about you
know does this cluster has this mutation
versus this cluster did not have this
mutation to think about French
devolution and where things probably
what is the first clone that actually
started this tumor progression and what
other clones that French tout as a tumor
began to go under clonal evolution so to
me heterogeneity exists as we know and
expect tumor heterogeneity can have
significant impact on identifying
drivers including those that might be
therapeutically relevant as we seen
before while looking at those heat maps
and going underneath some
those regions of amplification and
singing genes that have that are going
to be affected because this is a part of
the genome that's being highly amplified
and just so happen your gene of interest
whether it's an oncogene or tumor
suppressors being affected or for those
of you that are studying novel therapies
where you think that every cell has this
target because bulk sequencing told you
that but we look at a single cell level
you realize that only 50% of these cells
have this target only 60% a 70% of these
cells have this target which may relate
to treatment resistance or maybe the
reason why a patient did not respond
well to a therapy may be a reason why a
patient blew through the therapy may be
a reason why patient did not have the
response that you thought they would
have in the time that you thought they
had but maybe while patient went through
relapse recurrence you know these are
the things that I believe single cell
technology where there's single cell
copy number single cell mutational
analysis single cell RNA sequencing so a
taxi these things will give you some
type of it will shed some light on what
what are the reason this is happening in
this patient and what are we doing next
what could we do next when the next
patient comes in and they maybe have
their single cell profile it looks like
that or just on the research level where
we are right now is should I pursue this
therapeutic target when most of the
cancers that I see have 50 percent of
this target is actually being expressed
so 60 percent or maybe that's another
target that is maybe that's a 60-40
going on where you can think about
combination therapies when you're
thinking about you're a research design
or maybe finding a specific therapy to
use in combination with your therapy of
interest and you can start those studies
in preclinical studies
earlier before you have to find out in
phase 1 of phase 2 that this does not
actually show any promise so so these
are the things we're we're where we
should be these are the technologies
that we should be using to really
understand a patient's tumor or any
tumor that we look at because these
technologies will allow us to better
sample the entirety of a patient's
cancer to uncover potential clones that
are prime to induce recurrence
metastasis and/or drug resistance we
believe connection only single cell
technologies hope promise to help assess
clonal heterogeneity in an efficient way
especially in the realm of single cell
DNA single cell copy number were we
talking about
intra tumor heterogeneity we believe
outside of fish that this is the best
way of doing it and our hope today of my
our data actually showed that that this
does hold promise and hopefully in the
near future we can combine some of these
technologies with other novel
technologies as well as technologies
that are tried-and-true
and really put together a true
representation of a patient's tumor so
with that said I like to thank our
department my department the department
of translational genomics my mentor is
John Carson who as well as the who was
also the chair and co-founder of the
department of translational genomics all
of them played a huge role in helping us
with this Polish polish study and
critique dis analysis as well as all of
the new things that we've done using
this technology and they've contributed
not only to the work of this project but
also to be think tank of what to do next
and how to do in best ways to analyze
this data going forward
so thank you for taking your ticket time
out of your busy day I know many of you
are working lab work in hospitals and
you could be doing many many other
things that are just as important but
think you could take your time to spend
your this hour listening to one of the
novel approaches of accessing molecular
heterogeneity in cancer if you have any
questions feel free to email me or
follow the link to questions and answers
and I'll be happy to reply back as soon
as I see them thank you